we were fascinated by the back and forth
with Dan Shaughnessy of the Boston Globe
and Bill Belichick and Dan went in there
went into battle and he was looking for
an answer or at least maybe thought he
could get an answer with Bill Belichick
on that question that still remains
unanswered why was Malcolm Butler
benched during the Superbowl here is a
little bit of that exchange last year
last year last year I'm not focused on
last year coaches players universities
and we've talked about that that's
multiple months ago training camp
training camp we're getting started
we'll work on that right now we'll do
the best we can I'm focused on doing the
best that I can for the 2018 New England
Patriots that's my job that's what I'm
gonna do that's what I'd always done in
the past every day that I've coached
here I've done the best that I could for
this football team and I'll continue to
do that and right now my focus on the
2018 season about 2017 or 2014 2007 not
2004 2001 not 2000 I'm not focused on
any of those seasons they're done it's
important for me to have a good season
in 2018 I'm gonna do everything I can't
do that do the best that I can for our
football team that's my job and that's
my responsibility that's what I try to
do hopefully you can respect that but
maybe not Bill Belichick and Dan
Shaughnessy of the Boston Globe and Dan
joins us now dan good morning what was
your strategy going into that exchange
with Coach Belichick well I had talked
to his console area a day or two before
and attempting to get out to get a
one-on-one and you know I knew that was
a reach but I just gave it a shot cuz a
pretty good relationship for the years
and I have a lot of respect for
for a bill and what they do down there I
just you know because it would be
preferable to try to do this you know
one on one and not in front of everybody
and and as I said if you wanted that
this places he doesn't want to go we
don't have to go there and and but
anyway that that didn't happen it was
very respectful decline of the invite
and so I think to that degree bill
probably knew something was coming in I
just I understand the beat guys get get
beaten down down there and just you know
the reluctance dance or anything and but
this is Dan Patrick I'm telling you this
this is comes up everywhere I go that's
legit I talk to I talked to Troy brown
last night
you know thousand years in the league
part of this whole Patriot magic ride
and he said the same thing he said
everywhere I go that's all people want
to ask me and he said I know the players
it's it's it's it's part of their lives
so yeah I think it's a fair game first
day back you know opening camp and here
we go and and I new to that and I knew
he was going to Stonewall and the
fallback is often we're just talking
about now and what's ahead and so I
tried to dwell in that point what about
this year's team yeah this is something
you need to address with this year's
team let's make it about now and and and
do that and do you care that the fans
are not satisfied with this does that
matter to you so anyway again it's not a
party started down there I understand
that I was really pleased that bill
allowed follow-ups because that's a lot
of follow up for any any session with
him generally get your knees capped off
and that's the end of it so I thought
that was I respected that I would
appreciate that yeah I I thought the
follow up that that's where it turned a
little bit and least made him pause
because if you're a current patriot
player I would still want to know like
what did he do that that cost us perhaps
is Super Bowl we had a bad secondary we
made it even worse
like there's no explanation like this is
pretty amazing that it's been this quiet
that Eaton you know neither side has
said much about this yeah it's tough one
I mean you know this is a guy who
obviously won the Super Bowl in the
Seattle game three years ago and with
the great play at the end and he was an
all-pro cornerback and he played a 98
percent of the snaps this year
he didn't come off the field against
Jacksonville two weeks earlier and now
he's not playing
and it was just and you know they can't
get the Eagles off the field they lose a
game which they don't punt they put
together 600 yards of offense the
quarterback throws from 505 and they
still lose because you know
baddam oh she's out there arm tackle in
the second half Malcolm Butler even when
he's not playing his best game he
tackles and it was just it was curious
and it didn't look like they were
putting their best foot forward and you
know all these things came out early on
you know the weed and concerts and
curfews and illnesses and you know
interfering with the elections and just
you know they tried everything and and
Butler said none of that stuff's true
and he was backed up by teammates on
social media including Gronkowski
Hightower and Brady have you heard
anything off the record or just
whispered you know no there's always you
know he got in a fight with Steve
Belichick who's Bill's son is the
d-backs coach and you know I mean
there's no it goes on there's a million
thing you know he emptied out his locker
you know he wouldn't go for the contract
offer that they had you know bill bill
said we'll win without him and then kind
of got locked into it
I don't know has Malcolm said anything a
little bit I mean you know and he's been
very respectful but it's weird to Dan I
mean he was courted by by Matt Patricia
like hours after the game ended the
Lions are trying to get him and then
Vrabel another you know part of the the
group here does get him and it was very
quickly in the signing period like three
days or less and he got well well paid
and bye-bye expatriate guys going for
his services so that's curious too yeah
yeah it's it's a head scratcher what's
it like going toe-to-toe when everybody
is there watching the exchange with you
and Belichick well it's it's like
Belichick you got to be prepared and you
know I've learned that from Bill and Red
Auerbach and all my journalistic
forefathers you know just be prepared
because you kind of all these years you
sort of know he's not going to love this
but I tried to appeal to him as a sports
fan you're a fan I know he loves
baseball and he goes to Celtic games and
he gets it you know he's wondering about
LeBron James so just as that let's just
trying to just go go that route and I
tried to appeal like I'm doing my job
you know that was not an accidental you
know notion that I was I was tucking in
there that's what I'm doing and he
professes do your job so that's what I'm
doing and I again I thought he was
extremely for something he hates to talk
about and and doesn't want to go - I
thought he was extremely polite and
professional about it
have you asked Brady about what he
thinks of not knowing not I think
there's some you know there's all those
you know it's like reading hieroglyphics
and hints and stuff they there's been
some stuff in Tom versus time and maybe
with the Jim Gray interview where he I
think they want to Troy told me that
it's Tom at one point says it Malcolm's
talking to him on the sideline and Tom
say wait a minute why aren't you in the
game you know anything and I think you
know that they they were like oh we
really having our best team out here and
especially when you can't get those guys
off the field Dan they didn't punch and
they lost the Super Bowl it's impossible
if I said you could have all of the
answers to any of the Patriot
controversies so you could have the
butler benching why was Garoppolo traded
deflategate other you got to pick which
one these are the nuclear codes man you
got to pick one yeah I'd probably go
with with the really inner the inner
story and Jimmy G you know just because
I think that's got the owner involved it
might have Brady involved I think you
know bill identified the next guy had
pride of authorship cultivated him was
ready and Tom outlived the plan and they
couldn't have an organic transfer and
they couldn't franchise him and the
owner favored and the court the Brady
and oh my god I think that one's got
more layers is good stuff
you know I hope you had fun going
against Belichick do you feel like an
opposing coach going against him like
you said you got it like you really have
to prepare when you go okay if I ask
this this is probably where he's going I
don't know do you rehearse this and you
know at home I had like five things
written
I knew where I wanted to go and I was
allowed to do that and I appreciate that
so it was I was ready yes
but yeah it's like it's one shot man you
don't want to screw it up
thank you Dan we appreciate your time as
always that's a Dan Shaughnessy Boston
Globe columnist for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]